johannesbourg afrique du sud
[Musique]
les équipes au sol se prépare pour
l'arrivée d'un hélicoptère la tension
est élevée et la sécurité renforcée
c'est l'un des nombreux hélico qui
atterrissent ici chaque jour la
cargaison ainsi que sa provenance sont
un secret bien gardé à bord ni leader
international ni pdg d'un grand groupe
mais une seule marchandise de l'or sa
valeur plus d'un million de dollars
[Musique]
cet or provient du bassin de
witwatersrand la région des terrains
aurifère d'afrique du sud les plus
riches du monde
[Musique]
et les plus profonds ça ressemble à une
répétition pour la descente aux enfers
on sent qu'on est bien loin de la
réalité du voyage au centre de la terre
de jules verne
ces mines d'or plonge à 5 km sous terre
c'est là que force de travail équivalent
à celle d'une petite ville creuse 24
heures sur 24 des hommes qui triment
pour extraire un métal ayant toujours
joué un rôle crucial à travers les
civilisations
aucune autre richesse en effet n'a
autant présider à la destinée de
l'humanité
cinq siècles avant jésus-christ ce sont
déjà des pièces d'or qui tissent les
liens essentiels du commerce
des empires sont érigés et chute à cause
de l'or
les routes commerciales qui relie les
marchés d'est en ouest sont pavées d'or
de l'amérique du sud à l'afrique du sud
on s'est battu pour l'or
[Musique]
pour l'amour de l'or on conquiert le
nouveau monde et des civilisations tels
que les aztèques et les incas vont être
anéantie
on commence par utiliser ce métal est
insolent pour en faire des parures il
devient ensuite objets de culte
[Musique]
des israélites fondant leurs bijoux pour
en faire le veau d'or aux indiens
d'amérique du sud qui sur nam lors la
sueur du soleil les cultures ont
traversé les siècles avec la conviction
que l'or possède des propriétés divine
[Musique]
la bible elle-même parle des rois mages
venus célébrer le roi nouveau-nés en lui
faisant don d'or de tout temps et en
tout lieu de l'egypte au pérou l'homme à
orner ses palais et ses temples de ce
métal atemporelle on estime que depuis
l'antiquité
on a extrait entre 130 et 140 millions
de tonnes d'or s'ils ont fondé cette
quantité d'or en un seul et unique bloc
on obtiendrait un cube d'environ 20
mètres de côté soit un cinquième du
washington monument est la raison pour
laquelle on est aussi précis dans ses
chiffres provient de la nature même de
ce bien l'or est une matière
indestructible les objets en or
découverts dans les tombes égyptiennes
ont effectivement garder la même
apparence depuis qu'ils ont été créés
lors demeure intacte volontaires pour
deux mille ans ou bien qu'on le laisse
immergeait de milan quand on retrouve
une pièce d'or et fait exactement le
poids qu'elle faisait à l'époque
il est fort probable que l'or ait été le
tout premier metal travaillé par l'homme
il est extrêmement malléable
on peut étirer une simple once d'or à
peine 30 g en un fils de 80 km de long
ou bien l'aplatir en une feuille de 100
m² leur est si inaltérable qu'on
l'appelle le roi des métaux
il résiste aux ravages du vent de la
pluie et du temps
je ne crois pas qu'il existe un
quelconque autre élément qui est ses
qualités exceptionnelles
il ne ternit pas il bride pour toujours
et ne se dégradent pas l'argent s'en
rapproche le platine aussi mais il n'y a
rien de comparable alors on trouve de
l'or sur tous les continents
mais dame nature se le gardent
jalousement
le métal précieux est maintenue
emprisonné dans les filons de quartz au
coeur de la roche et si montagneuse
au tréfonds de la terre
soumises au travail infinie des vents et
des pluies
laroche alentours finit par s'éroder et
l'or par affleurer
les anciens se servent en paillettes et
en pépites qu'il trouve dans les cours
d'eau où les morceaux de roche
mais lorsque les rois commence à régner
il ne manque pas d'instaurer leur règle
d'or
le métal précieux devient leur monopole
quel que soit l'endroit où on le
découvre
[Musique]
donné son premier coup de pioche pour de
l'or revient alors à mettre le doigt
dans un commerce impitoyable
lorsque les égyptiens conquiert la nubie
il a servi son peuple aux mines d'or
lorsque les romains à conquiert ce qui
est aujourd'hui l'espagne il a service
le peuple aux mines d'or et quand les
espagnols conquiert le pérou eux aussi à
service le peuple aux mines d'or du pays
le métal obtenu est le plus magnifique
qui soit mais bien souvent les gens
qu'ils extraient travaillent dans des
conditions les plus inhumaines
il pleut misérable qu'on puisse imaginer
aussi je pense que puisque la recherche
de l'or a toujours été plus ou moins
incessantes
elle s'est souvent faite d'une manière
impitoyable mais l'or va bientôt se voir
soustraits à la mamie ce terrible des
rois
tout commence à basculer un matin de
printemps 1607 lorsque trois navires
jettent l'ancré sur les côtes de
virginie
[Musique]
johnston et le premier village
britannique digne de ce nom dans le
nouveau monde à s'établir dans l'espoir
de trouver de l'or les commanditaires du
voyage ont ordonné à ses fondateurs de
ne pas rentrer au pays sans rapporter de
ce métal jaune dont ils ont entendu dire
pour le trouver en abondance aux
amériques
parmi les premiers colons figurent deux
orfèvres et 2 affineur de métaux
mais la fièvre de l'or est contagieuse
le capitaine smith écrit dans son
journal de bord
la pire entourloupe c'était no affineur
tout clinquant qu'ils étaient avec leur
promesse doré il n'y avait pour eux pas
d'autres mots d'autres espoirs ni
d'autre travail que de creuser pour de
l'or l'avait lors affiné lors
seulement voilà il n'ya pas adore les
colons de jamestown vont s'aventurer
jusqu'à 60 kilomètres à l'intérieur des
terres sauvages dans une course insensée
de crédules qui croient bientôt toucher
aux miracles
ce n'est que près de deux cents ans plus
tard que l'on va commencer à mettre à
jour des quantités importantes d'or dans
le nouveau pays indépendant un dimanche
matin de 1799 conrad reid alors âgé de
12 ans sèche la messe pour aller pêcher
ce qu'il trouve ce jour là dépasse de
loin tout ce qui sera donnée de trouver
à john smith et à d'innombrables autres
pionniers américains
[Musique]
de l'or non seulement le bien le plus
précieux de l'époque mais surtout une
seule et unique pépites de 7 kg 700 sa
famille n'a pas la moindre idée de ce
qu'elle tient entre les mains
pendant des années elle utilise cette
pierre comme butoir de portes jusqu'à ce
qu'un bijoutier du coin en entendre
parler
il achète le trésor pour 3 dollars et
demi la pépite en vaut alors presque
au début du 19e siècle des milliers
d'américains sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
trouver de l'or sur les contreforts
montagneux de la caroline pendant trente
ans à tort qu'ils extraient aide les
états unis à alimenter sa monnaie mais
rapidement ce flux d'or se transforme en
un mince filet reste alors à découvrir
les grands gisements une découverte
effectuée à l'ouest de l'amérique voit
la naissance d'une nouvelle profession
le chercheur d'or c'est le début d'une
ruée vers l'or qui va transformer
l'ouest du pays le symbole chimique a eu
pour l'élément or provient du latin aux
roms qui signifie aube luisante
en 1848 une découverte accidentelle en
californie va offrir au tout un chacun
pour la première fois de l'histoire une
chance de s'enrichir grâce à l'or
tout commence en 1839 avec jones auteur
un homme ambitieux émigré du village de
camden en allemagne sauteurs se pose en
californie décidé à fonder un empire
agricoles sur les collines fertile qui
entoure la vallée de sacramento
c'est là qu'il érige un fort afin de
protéger ses biens en plein essor à
peine dix ans plus tard il totalise
mille deux cents têtes de bétail et plus
de 100 employés est il à ce projet qui
est de développer une minute rim afin de
pouvoir subvenir aux besoins
alimentaires des gens qui viennent
s'établir à l'ouest
pour ce faire cette heure a besoin de
bois de charpente lorsque l'ehpad
dénommé james marshall à douchapt ou
itinérants le mène au ford center
ce dernier l' embauche et lui confie la
construction d'une scierie les ouvriers
ont dû creuser un immense fossé pour
amener l'eau jusqu'à la syrie et
l'extrémité la plus basse du fossé qu'on
appelle le bief arriver au niveau du
soubassement du terrain c'est là que le
matin du 24 janvier 1848
james marshall qui effectué son contrôle
de routine a observé une faute au sol
dans laquelle il a remarqué un morceau
d'or marshall hésitent à deux reprises
avant de prendre la peine de se baisser
pour le ramasser
je me suis assise et j'ai commencé à
réfléchir très sérieusement j'avais le
coeur qui bat très fort j'étais certain
que c'était de l'or le morceau faisait à
peu près la moitié de la taille et avait
la forme d'un petit pois
[Musique]
marchal parcours ce jour-là 65 km pour
le montrer cette heure le cas elle
écrira plus tard monsieur marshall a
commencé par me montrer ce métal en fait
des petits fragments et spécimens dont
certains pouvaient valoir quelques
dollars il m'a annoncé qu'il en avait
parlé aux ouvriers à la syrie comme quoi
c'était peut-être de l'or 7h décide de
garder secrète la découverte jusqu'à ce
que l'un de ses ouvriers s'arrête en
ville prendre un verre sans argent sur
lui à la place l'homme fut sa poche et
en sort une pépite jaune trouvait dans
un ruisseau
il la pause bruyamment sur le comptoir
voilà de l'argent c'est de l'or
d'écarter la transaction a lieu dans une
épicerie générale tenue par un mormon du
nom de sam brannan lequel ces deux ou
trois choses sur la situation de l'offre
et de la demande à la frontière sains
brannan n'a pas fait ce que tous les
autres ont fait c'est à dire se
précipiter à la syrie pour commencer à
creuser
au lieu de ça il est descendu à san
francisco et à acheter tout ce que ses
bras pouvaient rapporter en matériel
dont les mineurs auraient besoin dans
les mois suivants puis brannan fait en
sorte de s'assurer que lit mineur
arriveront en foule il a arpenté les
rues de san francisco en criant haut et
fort la nouvelle de la découverte de
l'or dans la rivière américaine de l'or
de l'or dans la rivière américaine
lorsque la nouvelle parvient dans l'état
d'oregon deux tiers des hommes bons pour
le service font leur baluchon et partent
pour la californie il s'autoproclame
chercheurs d'or trouver le métal devient
leur nouveau métier
un fonctionnaire espagnol à monterrey
observe
les fermiers ont laissé de côté leurs
charrues les avocats leur dossier les
médecins leur pilule les prêtres leur
miss elle est tout ce sont maintenant
mises à creuser pour de l'or
les nouvelles se transmettant encore
plus vite par voie maritime
les chinois sont informés avant les new
yorkais les nouvelles ont mis tellement
de temps à parvenir à l'est du pays
qu'on a surnommé sega ceux de 49 en
l'occurrence 1849
au lieu de ceux de 48 en 1852 la
population de la californie a plus que
décuplé pour arriver à 250000 personnes
c'est pratiquement le monde entier qui a
participé à la ruée vers l'or on peut
lire sur les registres que des gens sont
arrivés du sous continent indien de tous
les pays d'europe aussi d'australie
d'amérique du sud et bien entendu en
particulier des états unis trois
itinéraires possibles vers les terrains
aurifère s'offre aux quelques 80 mille
américains qui quitte la côte est par
train le voyage prend jusqu'à six mois
par bateau en contournant l'amérique du
sud il peut aussi durer six mois ou bien
encore par voie maritime et terrestre en
empruntant l'isthme de panama le chemin
le plus court mais aussi le plus coûteux
ces trois solutions engendrait de toute
façon énormément de souffrance il y
avait la faim et la maladie terrible les
nombreux dangers aussi il ne faut pas
oublier non plus le mal du pays et la
peur l'inquiétude aussi à la fois pour
la famille qu'on laissait et pour ce
qu'on allait trouver pour survivre en
californie lorsque les bateaux accostent
à san francisco les marins alléché par
la perspective de gagner 20 ans de
salaire en seulement deux mois de
prospection se joignent aux passagers et
les accompagne dans cette ruée vers les
régions aurifères
le ss californien arrive en avril 1849
avec un équipage de trente six hommes en
quelques jours il n'ya plus à bord que
le capitaine et un mécanicien un autre
capitaine de navire va même jusqu'à
pendre aux extrémités d'une vergues deux
déserteurs en guise d'avertissement
mais en vain la fièvre de l'or fait
délirer le monde c'était la chance de
toute une vie pour beaucoup de gens qui
ne connaissaient que la pauvreté
tout à coup on leur annonçait cette
nouvelle extraordinaire avant la
découverte à la syrie de 7 heures lors
que l'on trouvait devenez immédiatement
propriété des rois et des conquérants la
ruée vers l'or californie introduit une
nouvelle donne ou tout simplement la
chance pour le commun des mortels de
pouvoir chercher et garder pour son
compte tout ce qu'il trouvera vous avez
là tout à coup des mineurs indépendants
qui se débrouillent seuls dans le froid
et la pluie qui extraient et fouillent
le gravier aurifère à s'en briser les
reins
c'est tout à fait unique dans l'histoire
du monde
les gars de 49 déniche une région
rocheuses riche en or qu'on surnommera
le filon mer au fil de réunions d'année
l'or est emportées par les torrents et
parvient jusqu'à la rivière
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de sable de
gravier aurifère mais si la californie
est inondée d'or l'argent lui même se
fait rare le point d'approvisionnement
valeur le plus proche et philadelphie
situé de l'autre côté du pays
les californiens vont donc improvisé en
utilisant la monnaie étrangère présente
sur place
le dollar espagnol en argent appelé la
pièce de 8 et est ce qu'on trouvait le
plus communément il leur fallait le
découper en huit petits morceaux chacun
ayant une valeur de 12,5 cents pour six
morceaux par exemple on avait droit à
une coupe de cheveux et un rasage
mais david broderick nouvel arrivant de
new york commence à racheter de la
poussière d'or en la fondant pièce il
permet aux californiens de se constituer
une réserve d'argent devenu désormais
indispensable on s'est aperçu plus tard
que cette pièce soit disant de 5 et de
10 $
or n'étaient peut-être pas faites
uniquement d'or broad eric s'est donc
constitué un bon pactole avec son
affaire
broderick n'est pas le seul entrepreneur
à faire fortune sans avoir jamais touché
la roche à l'apogée de la rue et sami
anan qui ravitaille alors les mineurs
devient l'homme le plus riche du pays
john brennan est connu comme le tout
premier millionnaire un million de
dollars en poudre d'or sans avoir donné
un seul coup de pelle
cependant seule une poignée des gars de
49 sortira riche de l' aventure en 1849
la californie a produit 10 millions de
dollars en or / une moyenne de 40 mille
mineurs cela fait approximativement 250
dollars par tête mais les gens
continuent d'affluer par centaines et
par milliers attirés par les histoires
extravagantes qu'on raconte sur cette
ruée
en 1851 la production atteint 77 tonnes
la majeure partie par pour l'est du pays
une cargaison annuel dont la valeur
dépasse le budget fédéral tout entier en
on atteint les 93 tonnes mais lors
facile qu'on pouvait laver à l'abattée
dans les ruisseaux et les rivières est
d'ores et déjà pratiquement épuisé
l'heure du déclin a sonné pour la ruée
vers l'or californien laventure n'aura
duré que quatre courtes années mais elle
reste fondamental pour le développement
à venir de l'ouest américain a été d'une
porte est bien supérieure à toute autre
aventure de ce genre dans l'histoire
pas seulement pour la quantité d'or
extrait les pour ce qu'elle a
concrètement apporter aux états unis ces
mineurs à cour d'or qui se sont aperçus
que ça ne valait pas le coup décide
alors de revenir à ce qu'il maîtrise le
mieux
il crée donc des fermes aux californie
qui s'avère plus productrices
comme pour le reste de l'histoire de
l'ouest américain le développement a un
coût l'immigration massive bouscule un
système économique et social en place
depuis des siècles les différentes
reuver vers l'or en tuent des effets
dévastateurs sur les populations
indiennes ça a été le début de la fin de
leur mode de vie
en l'espace de cinq ans la population
indienne en californie passe de plus de
cent cinquante mille habitants à moins
de 30000 la plupart des victimes meurent
de faim ou de maladie
les autres sont assassinés par les
mineurs
les initiateurs de la rue et suivent un
chemin analogue james marshall l'homme
qui avait trouvé la première pépite dans
la rivière passe le reste de sa vie
ivrogne faucher a cherché en vain à
notre gisement
quant à l' empire agricole prospère de
jones auteur il est anéanti ses ouvriers
se sont rués vers les champs aurifères
avant donnant les terres aux squatteurs
sauteur évoque dans ses mémoires son
rêve brisé cette découverte soudaine
d'or a détruit tous mes beaux projets si
j'avais réussi seulement quelques années
avant qu'on ne trouve de l'or j'aurais
été le citoyen le plus riche de toute la
côte pacifique
mais au lieu d'être riche je suis ruinée
certains gars de 49 ne parviennent
pourtant pas à se débarrasser de leur
fièvre de l'or dans le demi-siècle qui
suit d'autres rues et au lieu de par le
monde
chacune d'elles déclenché une véritable
migration de chercheurs mu par la seule
rumeur de la prochaine grande découverte
dans la fièvre de l'or un gars de 49
ruiné découvre de l'or sous terre la
veine principale d'or qui a alimenté la
grande ruée californienne le filon mer
comme on l'appelait est en réalité une
veine de quartz se comportant de l'or et
qui s'étend sur plus de 160 kilomètres à
travers les montagnes du nord de la
californie
en 1850 edouard hargreaves alors âgé de
34 ans rentre chez lui en australie
après avoir passé deux ans à chercher de
l'or en californie bien qu alors sans le
sou hargreaves s'aperçoit que la
géologie dans la région californienne
qu'il a connue est semblable à celle de
la nouvelle galles du sud en australie
il prédit à l'un de ses camarades de
voyage qu'il trouvera de l'or l'espace
d'une semaine
il ya autant d'or dans des pays où je
rentre en californie et sa gracieuse
majesté la reine dieu la bénisse me
nommera parmi ses hauts commissaires de
l'or hargreaves n'est pas loin de la
vérité
en 1851 à peine six semaines après son
retour il découvre en compagnie d'un
guide dont il a loué les services de
l'or dans sabathé
en six mois quelque cinquante mille
chercheurs la plupart d'anciens
protagonistes du rêve californien
s'entiche de l'australie
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tard les nouvelles de
la découverte parviennent en angleterre
accompagné de la toute première
cargaison d'or australien le capitaine
du bateau à vapeur thomas seifert note
écrit notre colonie est complètement
paralysé tout un beau garçon capable de
tenir une telle est déjà parti ou bien
par creuser à peu près tous les produits
alimentaires ont augmenté parfois
jusqu'à 200 % de leur prix
l'australie autrefois colonie
pénitentiaire redouté par les détenus
britannique devient subitement la terre
promise pour quiconque possède un rêve
et une belle
en 1852 372 me l'immigrant ils sont
installés
c'était simplement des gens ordinaires
qui se disait c'est la ruée vers l'or on
se lève on y va et on essaie de
s'enrichir mais comme pour la californie
la rue australienne sera de courte durée
en quatre ans tout leur niche en surface
et dans les cours d'eau est accaparé les
fanfaronnades d'edouard grève sont
devenus réalité la reine victoria le
nomme au commissaire aux terres outre
une bourse de 10 mille livres sterling
elle lui attribue un mandat à vie
bien qu'il ne découvrira plus jamais
d'or par la suite
hargreaves continuera d'être vénérée
comme l'homme ayant le don de
transformer en or tout ce qu'il touche
les ruée vers l'or californienne et
australiennes fond du commun des mortels
des chercheurs à temps partiel je
suppose que c'était presque devenu le
semis profession dans la seconde moitié
du 19e siècle
vous étiez chercheurs d'or l'oreille
constamment à l'affût des derniers
potins et les derniers mots d'ordre qui
courait dans les bars avec la californie
et l'australie dorénavant hors jeu
l'ultime mot d'ordre devient aller dans
les rocheuses abily alors âgé de 40 ans
n'attend pas qu'on le lui dise deux fois
en 1859 il quitte sa ferme de l'arkansas
après avoir entendu une rumeur circulant
parmi des mineurs travaillant le long de
la rivière et selon laquelle il y aurait
de l'or dans le colorado au printemps
1860 lee trouve enfin ce qu'il cherche
dans le ravin d'une montagne c'était
plein d'or et il y avait plein de
couleurs qui roulait dans sabathé et il
a fait le rapprochement à ce moment là
j'ai toute la californie dans cette date
et c'est le nom qui a fini par recoller
aux rabbins le ravin californien c'est
reparti comme en quarante neuf
la première année le ravin californien
produit plus de 2 millions de dollars en
or cette première ruée était
exclusivement une ruée vers les sables
aurifère il suffisait de trouver le
métal selon une méthode qu'on
qualifierait aujourd'hui de méthodes
géochimiques ça consistait à détecter de
petites quantités d'or par l'action de
la gravité en remuant doucement la
battait
la découverte faite à witzwil rameute
des chercheurs d'or du monde entier
énormément de gens s'étaient déplacés
depuis les pays de l'est
au printemps 2008 170 mille personnes
sont arrivées pour tenter de s'installer
directement dans le ravin californien il
a donc fallu répartir rapidement les 8
km du ravin en petites concessions
individuelles la plupart ne dépassant
pas 30 mètres de long il y avait des
slovènes qui occupait l'ouest de la
ville les hispaniques était a string
town
les suédois sur ticket nil et les
irlandais dans la 6e rue
libreville où ville du plomb est une
petite agglomération d'à peine deux
kilomètres carrés vercher à quelque 3300
mètres dans les montagnes rocheuses du
colorado
la suite de la découverte d'abily les
milliers de mineurs qui affluent vers ce
qu'en recul et s'aperçoivent bientôt que
les parages sont également riches en
autres types de gisements au cours des
trente années qui suivent on creuse plus
d'un millier de puits de mine d'où sont
extraits de l'or de l'argent du zinc
ainsi que le métal qui donnera en 1878
son nom à la ville le plomb c'était une
communauté rudimentaire et désordonnée
je me souviens avoir lu un article
publié en 1893 qui disait que libreville
était la communauté minière la plus
célèbre que le monde ait jamais connu
les deux villes était réputé pour ses
salles de jeux et ses maisons closes la
proportion était de 10 à 20 bars jeu
maison de passe pour une école ou une
église
l'un de ces mineurs partis à la
poursuite de leurs rêves dans les rues
de lille ville n'est autre que thomas
soit à l'immigrant irlandais arrivé en
1879 pour chercher de l'or pendant 15
ans walsh pioche et tient le reste du
temps un bar à lille ville il a
auparavant travaillé dans l'une des
nombreuses affinerie de métaux qui font
vivre l'industrie minière de la région
en 1895 l'ironie du sort veut que thomas
swatch tombe littéralement sur une mine
d'or
c'est une chance tout à fait
exceptionnelle qui ne doit vous arrivé
qu'une fois dans la vie parce que
l'endroit au dessus duquel il s'est
établi cette masse riche en minerais
aurifères avait été fouillée quinze ans
auparavant par des mineurs persuadé
qu'il allait y trouver du minerai
d'argent des gens qui avaient commis
l'erreur de ne pas essayer comme on dit
pour les minerais
celui se trouvant à portée de leurs
pioches lorsque lui même a prélevé des
échantillons qu'il a essayé ce minerai
s'est avéré être très concentré en or en
on découvre de l'argent à lille ville
des centaines de mines poussent comme
des champignons pratiquement du jour au
lendemain
cependant les années 1880 voit l'argent
se dévaluer progressivement au fur et à
mesure que les pays du monde entier
passent un nouveau standard
l'étalon or la mort annoncée de ce métal
autrefois précieux se termine en
faillite totale
beaucoup des concessions sur l'argent
sont automatiquement abandonner aussi
dans les mois qui suivent
walsh rachète discrètement 50
concessions alors déserté qui
s'éparpillent sur les hauteurs entourant
lee de ville
il effectue des travaux de consolidation
et s'inspire d'une petite montagne
rocheuse surnommé le jet pour baptiser
son domaine la mine aux oiseaux
l'endroit va devenir la plus grande mine
d'or du monde et faire du web un
multimillionnaire il fait cependant
figure d'exception si quelques-uns font
fortune à libreville la plupart ne
trouve rien ou alors trac d'or la vie
dans ces communautés minières étaient
très très difficile tout le monde
s'imaginait que la pelletée suivante il
allait toucher le fils homer mais
malheureusement ça n'arrivait que très
rarement la plupart rentrés chez eux à
bord de chariots connaissent toga
typique de l'époque
très souvent il peignait une petite
maxime en guise de blasons sur la toile
du chariot tape dans le mille
ou rien et quand ils revenaient chez eux
à l'est il disait souvent qu'ils avaient
été plumés par dieu
alors que le 19e siècle touche à sa fin
les chances de faire fortune dans l'or
s'amenuisent
la toute dernière occasion pour les
chercheurs se présente en alaska
lorsqu'on découvre de l'or dans la
rivière klondike en 1896
des milliers d'entre eux des boules
le billet du voyage en paquebot qui
jusque-là coûté 50 dollar passe à 1000
dollars mais le bateau n'effectue qu'une
partie du périple
[Musique]
les chercheurs doivent encore parcourir
un long chemin semé d'embûches sur une
des terres les plus hostiles qui soit la
police montée canadienne safer
d'ailleurs empêché de se lancer dans
l'aventuré qui compte que n'en porte pas
avec lui au moins une année de réserves
de nourriture a major de la police
montée écrit on a du mal à imaginer une
telle scène de ravager de désolation des
milliers de chevaux étendue morts
jonchaient le chemin parfois par grappe
entière soudée à pic
il gisait à côté de leurs harnais de
leur sel de leur fardeau tomber avec eux
du haut des rochers
mais les chercheurs poursuivent leur
parcours sans se laisser abattre
puisque tant d'or avaient été découverts
dans tant d'endroits différents
il reste convaincu qu'il faudra peu de
temps avant qu'on ne met à jour le
prochain filon mer des gens avaient
l'habitude de se demander ni allait
avoir lieu la prochaine norme et la
californie est arrivé assez vite à
saturation
mais il ya eu tant d'autres histoires
dans les années 1850 et 60
on a dansé tout à coup de l'or à seattle
où ailleurs absolument partout et les
gens se précipiter alors que bien
souvent il n'y avait rien dans ces
endroits là ce sont deux solides
gaillards qui ont fait les grandes ruée
vers l'or du 19e siècle des individus
solitaires au rêve immense par payet
grain et quelquefois par pépite entière
ils ont lavé à l'abattée l'or qui a
transformé l'histoire
à chaque annonce de la découverte d'or
de la californie à l'australie en
passant par l'alaska
le monde entier s'est précipité pour
filtrer les rivières mais les cours
d'eau ne sont pas la seule qui achètent
de l'or on s'aperçoit bientôt que le
métal jaune se dissimule également dans
les collines environnantes
malheureusement il faut bien plus qu'une
simple pelle et une batte et pour
l'atteindre
l'exploitation minière de l'or rencontre
bientôt la révolution industrielle
c'est la ruée vers l'or australienne qui
permet de mettre à jour la plus grosse
pépite jamais trouvé un blog de 70 kg
d'or à la fin de l'hiver et au début du
printemps 1876
alors que le général george et caster se
prépare pour son prix ce tome on célèbre
rendez vous avec little big horn
les frères fred et moses manuel
s'affairent à chercher de l'or dans les
collines noire au sud du dakota né au
québec
les frères manuels ont passé l'essentiel
de leur vie arpentez l'ouest des états
unis en quête improbable door
comme beaucoup avant eux ils ont entendu
des rumeurs voulant que les géologues du
général custer les trouver de l'or dans
les collines noir le 9 avril 1876
les deux frères découvre ce qu'il
cherchait dans une zone connue sous le
nom de ravin du bauhb tail moses
relatent leurs découvertes dans son
journal
finalement la neige s'est mise à fondre
sur la colline l'eau s'est écoulée par
le filtre qui traverse le tuyau là j'ai
vu du quartz j'ai attrapé une pioche
pour essayer d'en casser un bloc mais il
était très compacte je suis tout de même
arriver et je les ai ramenés au camp
pour le concassé le laver ensuite à
l'abattée s'était plaint d'or en
quelques mois fred et moses manuels ont
extrait pour 5000 dollars d'or une vraie
petite fortune pour l'époque
un an plus tard les deux frères vendent
leurs mines pour quarante cinq mille
dollars
le gisement devient l'une des premières
propriétés de la homestake mining
company la création de la mine de
homestake annonce une révolution dans
l'exploitation minière de l'or au cours
des siècles suivants le chercheur d'or
solitaire équipés de sabathé de
s'appelle va progressivement cédé sa
place à de grosses sociétés utilisant de
nouvelles technologies
l'une des méthodes les plus efficaces
mais aussi les plus destructrices pour
l'environnement consiste en
l'exploitation minière hydraulique
il s'agit de faire passer d'un lourd
dans une énorme lance et de la projeter
avec force contre la roche pour en
désagréger les morceaux principaux en
balayant littéralement le quartz on
laisse ainsi apparaître là
les canons à eau anéantissent des
millions de mètres cube de terre et de
pierres à flanc de coteau sous des
pressions qui pourraient me utile et où
tu es un homme à 30 mètres en moins
d'une journée
on fait table rase du lit de rivière
qu'un bataillon de chercheurs bardet de
pelles et de battes et aurait mis un
mois à passer au tamis l'ancien site
minier datant des premières rues et
reprennent alors vie une autre
bénédiction tombe en 1889 pour les
compagnies minières il s'agit du cyanure
un incident mortel pour l'homme mais qui
s'avère être d'un grand secours pour
l'industrie on s'est aperçu que le
cyanure avait la faculté de dissoudre la
roche autour de l'or c'est devenu très
économique pour une industrie qui
utilisaient des techniques à grande
échelle et pouvait ainsi espérer
récupérer jusqu'au dépôt de très faibles
quantités d'or ces avancées en matière
de technologie minière fond de la mine
de homs take la plus riche de l'histoire
des états unis
pendant plus d'un siècle elle continue
de produire de l'or en quantité
régulière il représente 10 % en tout de
la totalité de l'or exploités dans les
mines d'amérique
fred et moses manuel avait découvert
l'une des énormes réserves d'or
dispersés dans tout l'ouest américain
plusieurs années plus tard en 1962 des
géologues localise dans les montagnes du
nevada un champ aurifère de plus de 1600
mètres de profondeur par 1600 mètres de
long mais l'or lui même reste invisible
à l'oeil nu
[Musique]
de nos jours la compagnie minière
barrick utilise des techniques
innovantes afin de récupérer de
microscopiques grain d'or de l'ordre de
quelques millièmes de millimètre pour
les voir il faudrait les grossir
pratiquement deux mille fois
après la découverte des gisements de la
région de carline ainsi que la mise en
oeuvre des technologies modernes
les etats unis sont devenus le second
producteur d'or au monde la découverte
des plus grandes réserves d'or qu'ils
soient est situé dans l'un des
environnements géologiques les plus
rentables et les plus exceptionnels de
la terre les voleurs savent que l'or est
dorénavant capable de révéler leurs
empreintes digitales
grâce un nouveau type d'analysés
chimiques capables notamment d'indiquer
précisément le lieu de provenance du
métal nous sommes dans la mine du grand
nord ligue au dans la région du
transvaal en afrique du sud
c'est puis serpente jusqu'à 5 km sous la
surface de la terre
chaque mois la mine traite une moyenne
de 209 mille tonnes de roches et de
résidus
en un an elle produit plus de 28 tonnes
d'or
le grand hall i go n'est que l'un des
très nombreux sites miniers exploitant
les riches terres d'afrique du sud
la signification de cette région pour
l'industrie de l'or est simple elle a
produit à ce jour près de 40 % de tout
l'or extrait à travers l'histoire un
jour de 1886 un fermier du nom de george
harrison travail à déterrer des pierres
afin de construire une maison dans la
banlieue de johannesbourg
lorsqu'il tombe sur un véritable filon
harrison autrefois chercheurs d'or
pendant la ruée en australie comprend ce
qu'il a heurté avec sa pelle ce n'est
pas une pépite d'or massif mais du
minerai de fer contenant de l'ordre il
vient en fait de trouver un minuscule
gisement de surfaces qui n'est autre que
la partie affleurantes d'une immense
réserve d'or souterraine laquelle
s'étend sur des centaines de kilomètres
à travers la campagne sud africaine
il n'existe au monde aucune autre
formation de ce type
l'afrique du sud est un cas tout à fait
extraordinaire dans le sens où l'on est
en présence d'un gisement dont les
géologues prétendent qu'il provient d'un
très vaste lac souterrain alimenté par
des rivières
ce serait donc que cette géologie unique
qui a généré la plus grande région
productrice d'or au monde
comme pour toutes les autres découvertes
de gisements la nouvelle de celle de
harrison se répand comme une traînée de
poudre
le problème c'est que la majeure partie
de cet or est enfoui loin sous la
surface
on a affaire des filons d'or qui
s'enfonce très très profondément dans le
sol
ils descendent jusqu'à trois kilomètres
et demi vous comprenez que ce n'est plus
du domaine du petit chercheur d'or lors
ne s'enfonce pas seulement loin
il est également difficile à traiter il
faut écraser 5 tonnes de roche pour en
extraire moins de 30 grammes d'or comme
pour les autres grandes découvertes d'or
à travers le monde à la fin du 19e
siècle les rêves de george harrison
comme d'autres chercheurs d'or vont être
récupérés l'époque où il s'agissait de
saisir la prochaine grande découverte
est révolu l'extraction de l'or en
afrique du sud en australie et aux
états-unis s'effectue dorénavant sous le
contrôle de grandes firmes
tout à coup apparaissent des compagnies
minières doté d'un gros capital qui
investissent massivement dans le
développement des mines d'or
elles sont suivies par une très large
main d'oeuvre prête à travailler au fond
de ses mines pas toujours dans les
meilleures conditions en 1900 l'afrique
du sud produit un quart des réserves
annuelle mondiale en or plus on trouve
dort plus les puis s'enfonce
profondément
certaines de ces mines descente
pratiquement jusqu'à 5 km avec des
galeries qui serpente encore sur
d'autres km et dans toutes les
directions
les mineurs qui travaillent pénètre dans
un autre monde
tout commence par une descente à pic en
ascenseur qui dure un quart d'heure vous
enlevez tous vos vêtements et vous
revêtez une tenue spéciale avec un
casque
ensuite vous rejoignez cette immense
cage il y a énormément de bruit et de
grognements tout autour de vous c'est
comme si vous descendiez littéralement
au centre de la terre
et plus vous avancez plus il fait le
choix
sans la présence d'un des plus gros
climatiseurs jamais imaginé la
température dans ses mines atteindrait
les 60 degrés centigrades
nous sommes ici dans les mines les plus
profondes de la terre celle où le
travail est aussi le plus intense
en afrique du sud les filons d'or
s'étendent sur des centaines de
kilomètres et personne ne sait jusqu'à
quelle profondeur il s'enfonce on sait
juste qu'ils sont très minces
c'est un peu comme si l'on observait la
viande à l'intérieur d'un sandwich on a
cette ligne très étroites qui sont les
écailles d'or emprisonné dans la roche
c'est à ça qu'on doit s'attaquer on
s'échine à dégager et à sortir de là
cette tranche à trois kilomètres et demi
sous terre une fois extrait du sol
l'or est affiné sous forme de barres
brut c'est à dire contenant 80 à 90%
d'or pur de la taille d'un petit pain
une barre brut pèse tout de même jusqu'à
32 kg une plaisanterie dans les mines
d'afrique du sud consiste à dire que si
vous parvenez à soulever l'une de ces
bars il vous suffit alors de l'emporter
et là vous vous dites ah oui d'accord
ensuite on place ses bars dans un
hélicoptère pour les convoyer jusqu'ici
pour des raisons à la fois de sécurité
de vitesse la cargaison est d'épouser le
matin avant ton heure
en l'espace de 36 heures cette barre
brûle aura été transformé en or fin
quarante huit heures plus tard elle sera
probablement déjà dans le coffre d'une
banque
quelque part dans le monde
l'affinerie rand est la plus grande
raffinerie au monde
c'est ici qu'on transforme l'or en
lingots en pièces en placage et enfile
près d'un tiers de l'or extrait dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité a franchi
les portes de l'affinerie rendent
il ya de fortes chances pour que lors de
votre montre de votre bague ou encore à
l'intérieur de votre bouche reviennent
directement de ce haut lieu chaque jour
en afrique du sud des hélicoptères font
la navette non-stop entre la mine l
affinerie puisant dans l'inépuisable
magne on est bien loin du chercheur d'or
solitaire de sa modeste battait et de
ses beaux rêves